again he knows his lane and other goods
[Applause]
just proper Bulls his way right to the
hole well that's what he can do turns it
in on Jones out to belly Williams will
drive Williamson another thunderous Jam
third of the night for Zion Williamson
Holliday the rebound quick outlet here
it is ball throws it down great
unselfish play right there by ball he
could have laid that up himself
they see how quick Williamson is from
the one end to the other now there's
another steal by Holliday Levine then
thousand to stop the fast break if
you're gonna play the way they want to
play and that is less here they were
third in the league and squad Oh again
he seems to be in the right place nose
really like that's person very good it's
yo soy high IQ of understanding where
the ball is and the angles of the court
that is young with a good finish off the
pasture walking on his team's dis
exchanging buckets
Lonzo crossover loses ankles Zion stays
i'ma say it again Joe that's not normal
that's not normal you don't shoot it and
then go get it that fast before anybody
else gets up to fool us do you think
he's got some hops at schnapps gonna be
coddling again quarter three and that
burned a ball all night long and that
ball gets to the paint and collapses the
defense he just played through the
contact didn't go to yoga cursed bucket
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
forty first overall Tim Conway
[Applause]
somebody from the 15th Road throw that
ball back go to commit ladies we're
gonna keep it going
he looks like he's back in the moment
that he saw Marcus smart coming side on
diving to the riddle is it safe holiday
forces another turnover Williamson
inside and throws it down a reason try
to get a piece of it and Zion Williamson
already with 10 points Williamson and
Ingram have 20 of the 26 points for the
pelicans and it's a violation inbound
violation looking to push tempo here the
pelicans number 5 in the NBA in fast
break points favors no the time is there
with the stick backslide
[Applause]
first points for Williamson he is fast
Williamson facing up and driving
[Applause]
eleven and a quarter efforts like hooves
clop horse eye
so balls perfected that with Williamson
19 points now for Zion and 10 shots
missed the layup and back home the
pelicans on the run-out they've got
numbers Williamson why he exploded over
and through Cleveland I liked the note
ball he got his legs back to fatigue he
was way up on the rim that time two
missed free throws after the mistake
[Applause]
or ferocious athleticism from Zion
Williams in New Orleans holiday gives it
up side
[Applause]
punctuation to gorgeous movements scuff
away Lonzo on the BAPS holiday give it
go to Zion
it's New Orleans routine say it with
your chest now listen he was not
standing there he came from The Granary
Luke roll down to getting into that area
for that box a beautiful pass by bought
9 points in 10 minutes for Zion Williams
[Applause]
[Music]
Williamson how about it the people
excited or what he came from the left
side of the floor and created his own
space 284 pound so ragged start
offensively
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's not normal I'm sorry you got it
that is not normal that is incredible
[Applause]
and take it away through holiday got a
piece of lime so saw it you saw it
signed off to the races he's got a half
dozen this is a textbook three on two
right here it's almost give it away
towards Willie Brandon Ingram kept it
aside from true
again man oh man the penetration he's in
no man's land so he's not he's not the
position to stop the ball from attacking
or effect that lob to Zion do you think
he's making himself available little
little and that's a great job by Zion
put nothing so far side they're in sync
aren't they
I told you Lance's great fors I'll work
well just going to the corner the glass
unless died on who the rest it's a
healthy partnership seven assists now
for Lonzo Dillon Brooks sit away from
Valanciunas who is averaging about six
boards four games but it's the rim and
the entire stanchion is still moving how
about the pass from Lonzo ball here's
Tucker in the paint no rebounded by
Ingram so they don't turn it over and we
get a spectacular highlight to start the
game please low turnover game New
Orleans that basket is still moving a
little bit to Ingram misses averaging 25
per game good for 13th in the league
he's scary
and that's why another reason Alvin was
so frustrated here we go
lob to Williamson and he smashes the rim
[Applause]
timeout Houston
well throw it up New Orleans favor yup
eighteen to six favoring the pelicans
westbrook hasn't punched out of there by
Williamson from behind ball what a pass
to a soaring Famers that's the next year
that Alvin was talking about in that one
sound we showed you get to the next gear
ghosted him explosive two-handed Jam by
Zion Williamson Santa Randy you know
he's going
[Applause]
Ziya with the block his way down against
to UCLA Bruins going against each other
the lobs
[Applause]
Betty is younger than rim so you know
what I'm gonna beat him to the lane you
know open earlier we talked about Drew's
patience and poise in certain situations
right there with the shot clock winding
down when a lot of guys will do
it's a pull-up for three right that's
excellent patience and that
pick-and-roll by doing the 24 assists 30
Meg sighs here's one in her nose clock
is down don't stop bet it'll be Nader
blocked away by
recovery the denial see and the thing is
if you're gonna keep this small lineup
in if you're Billy Donovan then AB
donators gonna have to make Zion pay at
this end that's gonna be tough game yes
[Applause]
that was that was a lot more impressive
than what I was about to say I could
tell you that that was a lot more
impressive and that's a good read by
French I was gonna say it's not Alonso
it's Frank Jackson clears out up against
door nice job
he saw
[Music]
three-point game and he's up to 21 in
county again there's a benefit to switch
in sion out on some of these guard right
that's the second or third time
[Applause]
just like a you day
[Applause]
legacy that carries on in Kendrick
Williamson from his AAU team a jobber
and crazy guys only took two steps to
cut down through he's probably he's
left-handed too right
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really tilt it down about here is
just beat everybody around the league
for a lot of guys believe me you gotta
make em pay you said it
take advantage its sion - drew that's
how you make them pay about that lead
that spells by three early the thing if
you're Erik Pascal you have to make a
conscious effort to Willy sprit Bank
because Zion is so good at rim running
good decision a good path another beauty
for buckets for dimes now you can an
opportunity to reset and get with the
last on the finish line so ball on the
dime that's what you get out of a reset
situation so it started off by not a
good possession and nods old reset the
offensive set and that's what you end up
with good German penetration and that's
playing in the pink mica inside hammer
sent home with the right hand
that didn't take long no it did not
points off the takeaway and this is the
team that we're accustomed to seeing
over the past 20 to 30 game drew poor
Zion it works it'll keep working and the
pals are up now on 11 295 rebound
up ahead Z train with a two-handed Jam
quickly the Lakers come back LeBron
throws it away that quick second jump
got the offensive board and throws it
down everything coming at the rim and
the free throw line for Zion Williams to
these no defensive balanced by the
Orleans to get back but here
[Applause]
[Music]
is off the shot clock for Drew with Zion
and a good entry again he'll stay with a
dull boy
a little bit of his own medicine right
there his break points favors no the
Thailand is there with the stick back
slam
[Applause]
first points for Williamson he is fast
once this ion works on read blocked away
but time stands with a flag
and that has the excellent division play
by Nasri but Zions ability to get to
that basketball and spring back up the
floor because I'm maxed well there's
also a reason the pals are way up in
second-chance points right example a
coming up look out
[Applause]
the Pettis with his team is at his best
defense too often get out transitions
and this has been something
[Music]
good plan tonight so gave it away on a
good read by a poky of the pass gotta
bet you didn't stop did he now you're
about to say yeah like John the Red
Devil rent has won every rookie of the
year prior to on the leaves ion greatly
throughout the other day tennis looks so
easy
his up China looks like he's uh he's
wincing parsy out of gas
[Applause]
rustles that is almost a full court law
man blonde so bald on target with Scion
Williamson D'Angelo Russell blows the
opportunity inside counsels saving drew
holiday coming up with Zion
he's got Lonzo in the corner and he saw
him early by Jordan Magoffin what great
court vision and then to make the pass
right on target
that's what's underrated like that is
not Zion makes it look easy
that's two looks at the PALS couldn't
tap it all tough break
now Beasley on the road on the trail
it'll be Hernan Gomez got a floor that
Derrick Favors took away that's
possessed get your money's worth
that was exactly my point their favor
state